[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
is it just me who has the term coolness
lost its edge search run on the internet
for the coolest anime characters and all
you get is a bunch of teenagers listing
off their favorite naruto and bleach
characters or whatever since apparently
all you need to do to be cool to these
kids is strike your favorite cliche
anime pose whether it be i'm too cool to
even be looking at you look how badass i
am if i stick my elbows behind my back
or my personal favorite me and my giant
[ __ ] it seems like giving a list of cool
characters nowadays it's just an excuse
to splat out your list of favorite
characters cool or not and even though
making a list on the internet is the
number one way to generate nerd hate
since about 99 of people find it
inconceivable that other people have an
opinion that differs from their own i've
decided to make my own list of
characters who i really think fit the
rule of cool this isn't a list of the
most badass anime characters or list of
who can be most violent or who can beat
up who no this list is for the type of
characters who can kick your ass and
make you smile scare the [ __ ] out of you
while still being cool do some
jaw-dropping awesome feats and still
doing it while looking stylish or just
keeping a swath demeanor about them when
they can be doing the most mundane task
they could be a villain a protagonist an
antihero or any other type of characters
because just their presence on screen
can make the scene they're in just that
much more epic yes this is the top 20
most epically cool anime characters okay
now for the ground rules i limited the
list to one character series just so as
not to bore you guys with the same thing
over and over though the system had to
leave off some potential list makers
just because there's a more suitable
character in the series also this list
will probably contain spoilers so if a
series pops up that you haven't seen yet
you might want to be a little bit
careful now even though i've already
mentioned this this is my list and
therefore it's just my opinion whatever
constitutes a character as being cool
it's obviously very subjective from
person to person though having said that
i did try to judge every character by
the same criteria which can be seen here
also i haven't seen every anime series
out there so if you think i've missed
someone or think you can do your best
list yourself feel free to post a video
response just so i know that you guys
don't blindly agree with everything i
say anyway so with all that out of the
way
let's get started
number 20.
[Music]
is
[Music]
first
[Music]
[Music]
and just to make myself a complete
hypocrite to my opening introduction the
first character on this list is a bleach
character but before you people call me
out for that let me just explain myself
there was a time when bleach was a half
decent shonen storylines weren't so
predictable and won't rip off of
previous arcs ichigo wasn't a total
pansy i can actually win fights to save
his life without relying on his super
saiyan hollow transformation nine tails
gear 2 power-up and kubo wasn't content
controlling his entire fan base at every
given chance but this time has long
since passed and because of this people
who haven't seen these just dismissed
all of bleachers another bit of generic
shown in dribble and people who have
seen all the bleach have forgotten how
[ __ ] cool eisen's introduction
as a villain was originally eisen seemed
to be one of the kind of characters in
the whole show someone who cared about
his subordinates and who actually gave a
damn about the system that governed soul
society which is why his murder came as
such a big shock to me as to why he got
killed before getting much development
at all i thought he was going to be one
of the good guys helping out the
protagonist and sticking it to the man
but in the end he just died so quickly
and well
at least hinamori seemed to be a little
bit depressed by the whole
[Music]
event just a little bit
turns out he can have been a more
opposite character not only had he faked
his own death and had been planning to
take over soul society in one of the
most shocking twists in the series but
he was also completely ruthless and
displayed strengths unseen by any
character in the show so far i just
remember how shockingly awesome it was
to seeing characters dropping like flies
one by one against this guy oh look
hinomori gets to see her captain who she
loves again oh well isn't this a
touching scene
hold on a second it seems kind of weird
nothing's gonna happen to him oh [ __ ]
okay hits you guys piss now and he's a
captain too this is going to be one head
of an awesome fight let's see so oh no
wait he's got two and there's renji
trying to honorably protect rookie with
all his willpower and strength
okay let's be honest with you [ __ ]
yep wait hitchcock's just showing up now
some shit's going to go down he is the
main character after all so you must
stand the chance but even his teammates
have come up this is gonna be awesome
okay he's powering up now and then he's
off are you ready for it are you ready
for the most awesome attack ever here he
comes he's running through him now with
his bunk eye look he's about to swing so
look he's gonna he's gonna
huh well
[ __ ]
oh you better watch out again
see eisen's introduction back then made
up for some of the best episodes of the
series partly due to the twist being
genuinely surprising but mostly due to
how damn cool eisen looked while
revealing it all being the excellent
actor that he is he was able to fool all
the characters while manipulating all
the events from behind the scenes so
that everything went according to his
elaborate plans while no one not even
the audience suspected a thing
here was a character who we thought was
a genuinely nice guy and he turns out to
be one of the most ruthless cunning and
downright untouchably powerful guys
while being so arrogantly calm about it
[Music]
[Music]
you just gotta love his super sexy
transformation sequence in the end where
he mimics basically every movie makeover
in history at the beginning we have this
nerdy white boy who looks innocent but
all he has to do is pull his hair back
and take his glasses off and suddenly
his sex appeal increases by 150 superman
style but unlike superman he doesn't
look like a big pillock with glasses in
a suit when he's clark kent as the
series goes on we find out he's a
character who plans for every single
contingency and never lets anything
surprise him as he likes to show the
audience in one of his epic monologues
again and again and again like he gets
paid 50 extra for revealing his fan in
the most long-winded way possible though
this is also his greatest downfall on
the list later on in the show eyes and
speeches just got progressively more
ridiculous because this guy apparently
has the foresight of a [ __ ] time lord
when it comes to the number of events
that he foresaw and planned for to the
extent of his final masterful reveal
being that he has been following ichiko
from birth and have been planning his
entire growth by purposefully setting up
each and every opponent that he's fought
in the series so that they are just at
exactly the right level for him to beat
them and gradually grow his powers to
which i'm sure me and the rest of the
beach community collectively went
and this is all thanks to kubo's
inability to write eventually eisen was
just using some kind of plot twist
device spotting off some new contrived
plan that he'd been setting up for ages
that made no sense or just easily
covered up some plot holes that and his
final and most badass transformation
signaling ultimate power and lost hope
for all humanity is apparently turning
him into a [ __ ] fairy why do we call
him the fairy because he's a fairy when
he has wings he can fly sprinkles magic
dust all over the place he's homosexual
having said all that it is impossible to
forget the feeling we first got when we
saw his badass entrance into some of the
best episodes of the series and if he
had stayed like that then he would damn
well be near the top of the list but
thanks mostly to kubo shoddy writing his
place on the list stays at the bottom
number 19.
and now you die
[Music]
hey
darker than black
it's him
pk201
hey aka lee sanction it's lee shengshan
lee sanction
whatever aka the black reaper aka
chinese electric batman
is one of the many cool things to come
out of dark than black an undercover
contractor working for a syndicate
called well the cynica by day he's a
timid good natured chinese exchange
student going by the name lee
it's lee shengshon
whatever but by night he becomes a black
reaper a ruthless calculated individual
who has no qualms killing anyone to get
the mission completed he possesses
incredible athletic ability allowing him
to perform acrobatic maneuvers in
mid-air and is also an expert in
hand-to-hand combat making for a
fearsome opponent along with his cape
his trademark weapon is a knife attached
to a piece of metal wire which uses both
as in life and also as a grappling hook
to climb buildings and swing around
batman style with incredible ease and
topple that he can do this
i guess you should have listened to your
buddy
hey has the power of being able to
discharge electricity which he uses to
dispatch his opponents either through
direct contact or through the metal wire
tied to his knife combining this power
with his quick wits and superior
fighting skills makes him one of the
most powerful characters in the series
and before i forget to mention it again
chinese electric batman
yeah so those three words don't explain
why he deserves a spot on this list and
i guess i have more explaining to do the
way dark and black worked was that the
series was split into a bunch of side
stories focusing on different aspects
and despite being the main character and
always present in every episode hey was
hardly ever the main focus of the
stories this allowed him to drop in and
out of the story as he pleased meaning
he kept some mystery around him and also
made sure that every time he did show up
you knew something cool was gonna go
down sometimes he would show up as a shy
timid exchange student who no one would
suspect it's lee shengshon and the next
moment he could turn into the cool slick
assassin that is this guy a very
rational proposal i'd expect no less
from a contractor
though we do find out bits and pieces
about his past a lot of it is left
unexplained
originally he was already a famous
soldier in the heavens gate war adding
the name of the black reaper even before
he got his powers during his time hey
somehow came into possession of his
electrical powers which he got from his
sister somehow he's never actually
properly explained how he got his powers
from his sister since to be honest
absolutely [ __ ] always explained
properly in the show yeah i know that
all the phenomenon in the show is just
used as a setup but when you're throwing
around terms like anti-gate mata
particles synchron radiation and
garfield you mean garfield garfield
garfield garfield garfield garfield's
you could at least make some effort to
explain what the hell is happening
anyway if this guy's nickname is chinese
electric batman
why is he not high on this list five
words darker than black season two
was [ __ ] okay that was seven words but
shut up i could make a whole rant video
about what season two did to the dark
and blacks franchise but to paraphrase
they took everything good about the
original series and shot all over it
taking yoko kano's brilliant music and
changing it to some completely
forgettable pieces replacing mao the
cool black cat with alvin the chipmunk
and worst of all turning hay from one of
the coolest slickers assassins out there
into an emotionless homeless drunk hobo
who acts like he's been beaten one too
many times with the emo stick and looks
like he's trying to cosplay sutter from
welcome to the nhk and is it just me or
is hey kind of a lolica
i mean if the only female who seems
interested in you is a hot uptight
high-strung policewoman who has a big
neon sign on her forehead saying someone
just needs to loosen me up intent and
you seem to be more interested in
hanging out with girls who look like or
actually are about 13 years old while
ironically enough look like a sexual
predator with a pedophile beard you lose
some coolness points
but i digress strip away season two i
wish i really could and hey would be the
same butt kicking assassin that he is
with his batman style appeal and his
electrical powers he definitely deserves
a place on this list
you